こんにちははじめたそうです
100番円企画
何だー
[音楽]
久下で100万円曲第2弾です第1弾は世代内卦を作ることに100万円打ち込んだと
いう動画だったんですけど
第二弾は
もう
誰の子供から珍しい集来るために使いました
いい担ぐ悪くなっちゃうんですけどまぁなんといっても14feb 私肇社長の誕生日
だったんでなんかこうなんかなくあのさん自分に100万円使うってなんかすごい嫌な
んですよ
目立つ100万円作ってるんで干したいこと欲しい事もん
ライブでもないんですけどね不思議私欲のために100万円って考えるとなんか
もったいなって思っちゃうんですけども
動画にするんだったらまあいいやと思ってちょっとこれが欲しいなって思ったほど穂別
と買ってみましたまずは vtr をどうぞ
5着で今は100万円ことのエロい店をちょっと間違えたこちらのカードショップ a
使ってきたと思いますスパイラルっていう
をするになってるお店ですね入っていくそうですねパッと見
エロい店にいきそうですね1万円しか売ってないみたいですかいぞ
ここです
引き続き店これが10代ですあ今日は出し合ってい下せー
小沢シムカード見てていいですかいいですよ
ありましたこちらですはいこゆみさせるさっき
こちら
こちらのカードですねお値段がもうゼロの桁がおかしい
もったいないとか思いつつもん
アリアナ
天井
あの
[音楽]
いいいい
店長のカードくださいん
鹿島にまず等で食べきた
恐れのことですねはーい
はぁ
[音楽]
こちらになります a
うーん値札もうどうぞ
これ本当のでたんですぼったくりでありませんエイムリー
5貧弱ありがとうございましたでを買いチューブ入りますよピックピピピッ
エーサク20万円になりますちょ
では来てじゃあこれでドーン
[音楽]
ブーブーエロそりゃあの20万ちょちょ
一緒に中お願いします確かに受け取りました
失礼致します
趣味でお会計120万円ちょうどお預かりいたしますチーン
oo 作る家ておきますはいいや
さあ今ないとかやっていると思ってなかったなぁ
ストン
ごめんねこの紙袋で悩めしてくださいよ
こちらではいありがとうございます
ありがとうございました本当にございましたありがとうございましたまた来てください
1,200,000円
カッコずから20万1万120万円の有業カードを買ってしまいました
バカと言われても仕方がないいいんですいいんです誕生日だからさあ誕生日管キター
欲しいの買ってを入れたっこいでハッピーなカーレッジやるというわけでも本当に純正
にうわっ
欲しいなら手元に持ってたいなあこの集に収めたいなと思って買ってしまいました
この中に120枚の余裕カードが入ってます
くわいなぁじゃあ今日いきましょう受けてみようそう
[音楽]
はぁ岩井ファイルも日札に札遊戯王
シークレットブラックマジシャンガール120万円タッカー
2年ほどの間がちょっとしょうもないんですけどすごいですよもうやばいず何枚の厚紙
で守られていることか
数え切れない奴國榮何ございまって
えっなんかおまけられるのが入っている
てんちょひょっとしておまけしてくれましたで[ __ ]じゃまずはまず思い家から見て
いこう
何なにくれたんだろもっと口聞いてないんですけどだーっ
おかんだけどブラマジガンが入ってたこれ102地松ないほどブラザーズがですねあと
は
をブラックマジシャンのウルトラれるですこれでもめっちゃ暗い奴らこれも高そうです
ね
2なくマザーがある地区じゃんそれにすごい
こいつが海外の人
またどんなに入ってるこれじゃあまたはどんだけ入ってるのを待って待って待って
防具で多くないあってそんなにありがとうございます
ブラックマジシャンガールが何と true ブラックマジシャンガールとブラック
マジシャンが入ってましたありがとうございますそうブラックマジシャンガールって
たくさんあるんですけどその中でもですからいろんな種類があったよって値段が全然
違う
ですよそしてこの中に入っているのが世界でももう唯一
数えるぐらいしかない伝説のブラックもちろん通りでございます
はにゃすげー肝臓だと思ったら全然黒が可愛らしいですね見ていきましょう
あっあって何か言ってた入ってた衝撃的になんかなんかあれですね長兵衛書みたいな
血統書付きのブラックマジシャンガールですこちらこれはもうほぼバッグ3才からです
ブラックマジシャンガールの
本物シークレットレアですほらもうで1枚のカードにこんな暑いねー烏丸で使っちゃっ
てもう
やってねやることいろんなダーク明さんからがありますけどこの子は妄想性証明の本人
ですからねうん
本物ですねやはり何か強盗とか入られそうだどれぐらいの価値があるんだろちょっと
調べてみよう
あったあったあったメルカリであったんですけど160万円で打ってますメルカリだと
買う人いるジークレッドレイヤーの備品が本当にない出す来ては羽田のソーマが全然
わかんないんですよね保存状態とかいろいろあるんですよたボルダーと結構値段下がる
し
これみたいに超
美品だと高かったりしますね2000年の7月に開催された大家優勝賞品のブラック
マジシャンガールらしいです17年前に出てこの世界に300枚しか打てないつの綺麗
な奴だと今だいたい120万またはそれ以上キリルする
[音楽]
鍛造るに矢部も買っちまったなぁ数7年前の撮りでこんな綺麗だてっぱ
すごい子かわいいなおい可愛いないやーでまたにボッタ
5年前泥棒時てもこれだけはちょっと死守しようと思いますはいというわけで誕生日に
100万円120分か
特に10枚の営業カードを買ってしまった
動画でした
お願いしますみなさん
ウズ学んでください
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ
いっ
出します
須磨なってください私